so Pam I wanted to start with you and
just kind of ask you to just kind of
give us the background on on on the
story and how you came to it and and met
wash and Richard well I know wash and
Richard a long time they're good friends
with Todd Haynes who's you know in the
killer films family and while we were
making their second film the last of
Robin Hood they were telling me about
still Alice which was a book that two
really smart British producers Lex
Lutz's and James Brown had optioned and
just had the good sense to hire wash and
Rich to adapt and that had happened
before they even made the movie I was
making with them at the time you were
involved and attached and Julian's loyal
to us and had said this movie gets made
in New York I want Pam and Christine to
produce it so we all came together on
the basis of this wonderful story with a
great filmmaking team and of course for
us anything Julian wants us to do we're
going to do about the story is that in
in in looking at this disease of
Alzheimer's it's taking the focus away
from the family and the friends who
experienced the loss but actually
putting it at the point of view of the
person so I'm curious you know what were
your first impressions when you read
that script I mean I was absolutely
blown away I mean that is very very rare
I think generally when you when you read
any movie or any any study of a disease
is always from the point of view the
care taker and this is the first that I
had seen it was completely subjective
and it was fascinating when I I read the
script when I went back and read Lisa to
know it was a book and was really struck
by that was that the process was what I
felt when I was reading the book is I
felt as if it were happening to me
and I think that's the the strength of
the story and hopefully the strength of
our movie is that you can actually
experience the lost arts begins to feel
personal you know because it is so
incredibly subjective and that was what
I wanted to find my research to that
that thing we were just talking about
outside we're start the scene where the
says what does it feel like that was one
of the things that I asked everybody in
my research and and one of the things
that I asked two of the women was what
is it about your disease that you would
like me to represent and a lot of what
they said to me is in that speech
actually anything different about
working with these two as opposed to
working with other two co-directors you
know one of the things that I think the
misnomer about teams or about pairs is
that people are going to have different
agendas and what they do have generally
are different personalities and
different approaches and in the case of
wash and rich both when we were working
with rich she could no longer speak so
he was directing through an iPad but
what was amazing about him was how
concise he was you know wash is much
much more I don't know what would I say
he's he's but the most more emotional of
the pair and and Richard is the more
intellectual so sometimes we'll be like
well I don't know and kind of all over
here and this feels this way to go and
wash but just write something down that
was very concise and very precise so you
had the best of both worlds we're
getting directions from both oh yeah it
wasn't no no no and even there's even a
line where you know the line where Alex
character and they're all talking about
she's Alice's fairly declined they're
talking about what are they gonna do
with her where's she gonna go and I kind
of have been sleeping and I wake up and
I say it's hot in here and Richard wrote
that line on the spot because I was
initially like what's for dinner or
something I said it's gonna get a laugh
and we don't wanna get a laugh there so
what could she say
you know what kind of observation and
rich rich Bert you know quickly typed up
it's hot in here that's fantastic
and the the choice designs the book the
book took place in in Harvard Boston so
curious about the creative choice to
move it to live here do you know really
we all live here yeah we live here and
what's honestly what's the difference
what's the difference maybe a Harvard
when you're making a film with
limitations you really have to examine
like every single choice like what is
this bringing to the storytelling is
this vital to the story tell
and honestly it boiled down to there was
one thing vital to the storytelling
Julianne like let's make this as
comfortable and is in service of this
main care also has a tax incentive that
is just significant I've made so many
little what yes exactly
so for the last few years I've been able
to make these independent movies here at
home you know and but what was
interesting about translating it because
I used to because rich in Washington I
would get on skype and do the script and
in the translating of it because I'm a
New Yorker and they're in LA
have we said okay so she's at Columbia
and so then why she was like so she's
what she's running she's running around
Washington Square Park I was like no
this she's running uptown he's like when
they have a brownstone of Brooklyn I
said no yeah they're on 119th Street and
you know so all that stuff but all the
stuff that we know about New York and
how you live and where you are and we
tried to we all tried to put that you
know into the nearly yeah at Pinkberry
what'd you get that's my order at
Pinkberry berries in coconut yeah and
then of course specificity specificity
and behavior and and one of the things
that I talked about with everybody is
that I didn't want to do anything on
screen that I hadn't actually seen in
real life so all of my actions like at
all the physicality that you know the
picking the speech thing is the anger
the you know the the reaching everything
I had actually seen and that was very
important to me because whenever I
didn't understand something I thought
well I can't portray this because I
don't I don't know that this has
happened and people were so remarkably
generous when I spoke to them how much
time did you about four months yeah I
started I was working on Mockingjay
actually and then and then I was off in
November because there was a period
where they drop production on that and I
started working and then work November
and December January February then we
started in March yeah now we have to
talk about you know the rest of the cast
yes bill this story just brings up so
much about family dynamic and what
happened
when family is faced with a crisis so
tell us about this can I tell you about
Alex please do so Alec Baldwin and I had
worked together in 30 rock and I really
adore him and I just think he's so
talented and every time somebody would
send me a comedy I would email Alec and
say if you want to do comedy with me you
know and there's this thing and he would
always very politely decline he'd read
it immediately and then call me I would
say can't do I can't do it Jule no I
can't do it and so the last time he did
it he said don't you have a drama for me
and I said well actually I do you know I
said but I think the parts too small I
don't know if he'll do what he's like
sent it to me
you know I'll read it and he was like
I'll do it and then he called Pam he's
like I'll do it and every time I saw him
I was like has he dropped out yet oh
sure I wish to her that he'd be like I'm
not doing this you know and I can't I
still can't believe that we got him we
got somebody if such enormous talent and
passion and and and life he has so much
life so much vitality it's so much
energy it was kind of exactly what I
would I had hoped for in that role yeah
I'm just wondering too it's like do I am
I supposed to like him or we not
supposed to like him it was such a tough
position for him to be in to me I think
that that in the development of the
script that was a character we paid a
lot of attention to because I think I
have enormous sympathy for John and I
didn't at all want that character to
come off as sort of the foil of the
insensitive husband who doesn't get it
so I'm glad you're confused about how to
feel a little bit because he doesn't
know what to do and what breaks my heart
in that performance - watching all the
caretaking he's give he's doing you know
when he helps put on her pants you know
we order sync when he says to her like
no this is not what you like you like
this you know but then when he finally
says to Kristen you know you're a better
man than I am and he starts to cry and
you realize he can't do it he can't
watch it it's too hard for him he loves
her too much and he won't and he'll go
away before he'll see that and I had a
little bit of that too
yeah it was just wonderful that support
like I love the relationship between
Lydia an extraordinary Kristen Stewart
who I've known since she was 12 years
old
yeah and she's not any different she's
still the same lovely sensitive
intriguing exceptional actress and so
has had so much emotion at her
fingertips you know so so much available
to her and we really had at one of the
things that she said that was so lovely
in our rehearsal we were talking and she
was like I know what this is like I have
a mom and it's true you know cuz Chris
and I were talking we said it's not it's
not that there's some huge divide the
divide is that she wants to be an
actress and I want her to go to college
so it's not that we don't love each
other it's just that I I think I'm right
and she thinks she's right you know so
but in the end you watch them kind of
come together